all right carb up buddy tackle these
pancakes like it's fourth and goal on
the one-yard line
good one coach that's more fun when you
put stuff in football terms pancakes yay
oh uh we're actually out of those you're
gonna have to rush no no we put some
performance supplements in there that
could mess with you as a lady what else
is there well i'm going to the store
later in the meantime you can have some
fruit that's real i thought it was just
for show
my star player dwight has been living
with us ever since his father was
transferred to an army base in florida
he's doing his part for our country so i
thought
i could do my part for our team who's to
say who the bigger hero is i will he is
i've had to wake up a half hour earlier
to use the bathroom the soldier is the
hero
oh what are we gonna do oh sweetie i
know i'm ready to go yes yes
dwight and i are going shopping he's
gonna help me pick out some cool new
kicks like richard gere taking julie
roberts to the store that is right we
watched a pretty woman last night
i guess that would have been my window
to eat something
hi we're back i don't know what this is
but i love it there's mud out front so
dwight insisted apparently they're not
cool after you get them dirty oh
last night we also watched an officer
and a gentleman yeah he lifted me up
where i belong okay
yeah hi miss pasternack i got to go meet
some friends i'll see you guys later
okay be careful dwight here i brought
buy some more liquor bottles for lily's
project
what project i don't know i caught her
going through my garbage and she said
she needed liquor bottles well that's
weird anyway tyler i'll have a couple
more for tomorrow okay bye-bye take care
she can't babysit anymore what project i
don't know we've got a problem here look
what i found under dwight's bed oh
yeah it's too bad he brought such a
great energy to the house mitchell i
just need a minute to process this
oh i wonder who that could be
oh officer is there a problem
i'm here to arrest dwight bullock for
underage drinking
we wanted to give lily a chance to come
clean on her own luckily we have a
friend of a friend who dresses as a cop
for work he also undresses as a cop for
work
remember just act upset okay okay
dwight bullock
i have to arrest you
you've been a bad boy
but i didn't do it i'm innocent i don't
know how that bottle got under the bed
now we're gonna take it down a notch
hold on your wrists
i've got to take you downtown
dwight i am very disappointed in you
there's no more football
no more school
lily is there anything you'd like to say
to dwight before he's taken to jail
i guess
martha stewart said she used the present
time to work on herself that is enough
we know you put the bottle into dwight's
bed you owe him an apology this minute
it isn't fair he eats everything he's
always in the bathroom you're watching
movies with him shopping with him and
you two don't even love me anymore
lily honey
do you have the keys at these i usually
let the person who hired me find it in
my pants well if that is a custom i
mitchell
lily honey what are you doing
okay her first ice out be strong
lily all right come on
what you did to dwight was wrong okay
we're very disappointed in you yes and
there's gonna be consequences
no electronics for a week that'll be
worse for you then for me
no dessert
okay that hurts
that being said we could have handled
things a little bit better we should
have talked to you before having dwight
move in you mean i could have stopped it
well no but at least we would have known
how you felt and we could have made
things easier for you sweetie i of all
people know what it feels like to go
from being the center of attention i
went through it with my parents back on
the farm when they brought home a
seven-pound little pink bundle of joy
and said you're gonna share your room we
all know it's gonna be a pig anyway he
would snore
okay i'm sorry i lied thank you you have
to apologize to dwight too i'll try to
catch him in between bites oh
hey i have an idea let's think of
something we can all do together okay
just the four of us anything you want
absolutely anything
three years ago they gave me an
absolutely anything and i wasted it on a
popsicle
that was not gonna happen again
well now this is a lovely party it's a
splendid afternoon more tea no thanks my
cup is still full no it isn't but i
didn't drink at all just take the tea
[Music]
you